c'est vrai que depuis quelques temps
ciel on l'a vu dans le magnéto tout à
l'heure il ya des clashs entre les
chroniqueurs mais il ya une tension
particulièrement entre deux chroniqueurs
est ce que vous savez de qui alors royal
a beau franchement ya là beaucoup il y
avait il à bell et raymond ouais alors
j'ai une entière bernard et gilles alors
il ya gilles mathieu gilles gillet
bernard de réagir et dans tous les cas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors oui c'est vrai qu'il ya ici ray
kelly a dit lisa doby agile et bernard
gilles gillet belgique de gym et gym
la vraie attention c'est au tour de
gilles verdez et guillaume genton comme
j'avais même pas nous regarder le
magnéto qui passe et je vous expliquerai
pourquoi ensuite je pense qu'il faut
j'irai pas l'attaquer pour rien même
source guillaume genton à aulas voit la
preuve que gilles n'a aucun respect pour
autrui il m'a appelé antoine pendant six
mois à cyril parfois quand je vais aux
interpellé des gens ton parce que j'ai
peur de faire une erreur de prénom en
fait vous êtes transparent pour moi
elle a vu qu'ils vous étiez vraiment
massé qui est lady qu'elle était trop
m'en sors un hypocrite
comment la rupture a été consommée
moi je viens film insulter gratuitement
il m'a traité de looser non bâti ma
chanson loser
si si c'est un gars
c'est pas très urbain non mais cyril il
est temps de tout vous avouer être
devant les images si ça me permet de
revoir les tenues de guillaume genton
ce qu'il ya quelque chose il ya un
esprit un esprit de fête est ce la
raison en fait il ya récupérer votre
pull il a jusqu'au cou zut
alors il est temps de tout vous avouer
sachez que vous êtes vous le savez déjà
d'ailleurs je suis une petite merde
comme ça je le savais ce
savoir des vraies infos de
ce vrai c'est pour dire des lieux
communs non donc cette tension c'est
réel c'est moi qui les causes et non
j'ai décidé cette année d'être un petit
fouteur de merde à fouteur de merde en
espagnol regardez c'est de ma faute tout
ça
t
gilou sacha ça va
dit moi je en train de décrocher les
rushes pour pour lundi qu'il à la fin de
semaine et
et sur les rucks g guillaume qui
arrêtent pas de d'échangés entre les
débats genre vraiment été et et fracas
site [ __ ] je puis me voir c'est cette
blonde et tout mais vraiment sans mal
non
ouais
bah il dicte un [ __ ] de syrie il est
tout à fait à chaque fois que tu parles
que tu prends la parole à son talent par
l'argument juste une gueule et ça passe
en fait je vois la violence étaient
passés tes arguments pas cette émission
à dormir dans son coin il avait à faire
il commence à parler un peu de fatou
n'ont cessé jusqu'à la station sarah
gare alors bien tu passais dans les
loges il disait ça ça il pue le vieux ce
mec et après ils commençaient à pareille
somme toute façon tu vas pas sur un gars
il est lui l'ex à neuf depuis qu'il a
demandée en mariage est toujours pas de
nouvelles
c'est une merde sur les questions n'ont
pas besoin d'un
[Musique]
tacle pendant l'émission
j'aime pas [ __ ] la merde et j'aime
aller s'embrasseront gilou je pars
foutent la merde avait bien raison
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas beau ces bâtiments
voilà c'était vraiment un fouteur de
merde c'est un beauf garde à vous
attaquer
répond jean jé aucune leçon à recevoir
de gildan est élise lucet chez lidl déjà
et ensuite vous dire la vérité c'est que
gilles me supplie depuis des mois
d'apparaître dans mes documentaires mes
suppliques j'ai des preuves les et des
sms de vie il m'a envoyé un avion lirai
pas mais je dois je vais le dire je vais
dire
l'idée c'était d'apaiser les choses
bonsoir guillaume cgil je ne sais pas si
tu as mon numéro je te contacte car
valérie m'a dit que tu prépares un
documentaire sur jean jacques goldman
sach sache que je les rencontre et une
fois une soirée que fatou aime beaucoup
sa musique je serais heureux de
participer au tournage en spécialiste
musique par exemple très douce très fier
et on dit jamais non à une petite pige
je t'embrasse gilles
c'est vrai ça avec inventé mais sms je
peux vous attaquer en justice
je suis d'accord il sème déjà fait la
preuve vraiment sur le mec sa
chaude et des impostures
cyril monsieur cyril s'il vous plaît
quand j'ai vu mon doc sur disney m'a dit
est ce que je peut apparaître de danger
ramener ma famille a dit ce n'est pas
comme ces 80 dimanche mais n'ont pas dit
si je passe qu'il a lui-même lauréat que
mickey
voulais témoigner le vernis craque
gilles ça fait 8 fois tu vends à la
chaîne le même document
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les secrets de nice d si on n'a pas vu
qu'à sa
gueule et les secrets de disney mais
franchement y est comme nous est grande
il est bon
nouvelles fiches savais pas que mickey
n'a que quatre doigts
et je vais vous avouer qu'elle que ça va
mal et où il a vu le cinquième
je respecte di stefano oui ils sont
super poussins et dans le dernier il a
fait apparaître maxime guennic est un
ami et qui m'a dit tu sais pas pourquoi
delormeau m'a appelé pour chats dans son
documentaire comme il reprend les mêmes
images au moins il n'aura pas le même
interlocuteur et la victime de ça c'est
la chaîne et ça c'est dégueulasse parce
que j'ai la marge j'ai la marche que
vous faites et ce qui est encore plus
dégueulasse il me fait tout balancer
[Applaudissements]
la barre attendent attendent attendent à
touba tout prendre c'est qu'on a fait
cette somme et téléspectateurs linda
ménagères donc tu entends dire que sept
cent mille personnes est à dire le
compte y est pas bouger vous dit ça mais
ça donne à la maison
neuve qui se sont plantés inca marche
avait dû conneries ils ont tout marché
dont six étaient six à l'aide est-ce que
déjà ce sms envoyés guilloton est vrai
oui les forfaits montrer le moi et toi
est faite attention sera encore
plus hallucinante moi ça faux et usage
de faux yom ha ouais j'ai la prison la
mise en examen demain
quoi
non mais attendez
[Musique]
regardez à quoi station
donc c'est vrai regardez la réponse est
attendue vers lausanne ouchy
malheureusement tous les intervenants
sont bookés je te rappel si une
opportunité se présente d'accord merci
pour su qu'il soit possible de ne pas
intervenir à titre gracieux j'étais
coordonner les semoirs venir vers toi
j'étais sur gillet d'une merde non c'est
pareil c'est pas le régime je vais
regarder le nuit rothschild je connais
par coeur mais voilà plusieurs cyril
sauf celles en région c'est pas qu'il
verrait
la triche n'est pas numéro 10 il voit là
sa numéro 06 52 s'est pas
encore une fois guillaume genton vous
avez encore que c'est de la manipulation
c'est très grave je confisque déjà ça
je le mets dans mon slip
[Applaudissements]
j'espère juste que personne ne m'a
appelé mais si ça vibre
au
dollar à payer le double du prix
je vous le dis voilà comme ça ça c'est
fait
j'ai tellement envie d'appeler guillaume
[Rires]
a battu va savoir ce qu'on vit masi
ça sonne pas et chérif yoplait dont
gilles verdez vous avez vu je vous ai
encore mais sauver cette enquête a bien
joué encore sauvé merci série dédiée aux
gens tout c'est horrible matthieu
delormeau c'est horrible tous les deux
je vous enlève tous les documentaires
oui jusqu'à nouvel ordre la lah sur la
chaîne s'est vite sur le groupe pierre
et plus et surtout les gonds français
d'audiovisuel et même si bien
gilbert est heureux très heureux merci
cyril est ce que vous avez quelque chose
à leur répondre je peux vous avouer
quelque chose parce que ce que vous avez
dit que vous disiez tout donc si ces
annonces et alors tant que c'était au
détriment de la sienne je voulais pas
l'avouer mais le problème c'est que
mathieu voulait monter une arnaque à
votre détriment
vous avez une arnaque au président je
dois dire et je dois dire que guillaume
a résisté il a repoussé mathieu
mais non
ça fait maintenant alors
[Rires]
c'est pour moi un peu les français
[Applaudissements]
mais là
passé en carte bleue
[Applaudissements]
je ne travaille que la balance au
contact
[Rires]
à
chercher darcos tarnac dans les
documentaires tout est une affaire et
alors que la marche qu'on réalise
voudrait bien et voilà ouais c'est donc
oui et non mathieu est allé voir
guillaume en loge j'étais là cachées et
il lui a dit et puis on lui ajoute
guillaume il faut absolument que tu
monte les marches que tu fais donc mais
non non je suis désolé alors
il m'a dit mais c'est dommage je peux
pas quand je fais des docks c'est avec
cyril et monsieur lui a dit mais moi
jarnac sur la somme de jeu membres de
jarnac sur la somme que je demande il a
obligés à guillaume qui a refusé il l'a
obligé on le comprend rien ces
découvertes et les chiffres vous
arnaquer sur les marches qui réalisent
ces comoriens ont sorti les aigles avec
quelqu'un
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
non